we have a situation this is from a few
days ago
black tusk
can we take a look at the surveillance
footage she transmitted Atticus the
DARPA labs in the sublevels there are
all kinds of Defense Department
prototypes down there this can only be
bad news the question is how bad we need
to know which is where you come in agent
so after their defeat at tidal basin the
black tusks have been discovered at the
Pentagon it's hard to tell what they're
doing there but given that the Pentagon
is the heat quarters of the United
States Department of Defense it's
probably safe to say that we don't
really want them there the Pentagon also
houses the Defense Advanced Research
Project agency otherwise known as DARPA
this agency of the Department of Defense
is responsible for the development of
new advanced and highly classified
military technology for use by the
military so it's likely that the black
tasks are diving into the Pentagon with
this in mind in hopes of commandeering
some of this advanced technology to be
put to use against the last line of
defense in Washington DC
[Music]
you
my god early on in the mission we come
across a familiar face agent Sanders
this is the agent we were worth when we
were first alerted of the problems in
the Capitol when the shd network was
taken down
sure enough Sanders confirms that the
black tusk had been pulling the Pentagon
apart taking anything they deem useful a
plan was made with Sanders creating a
diversion the division was to find a way
around the black tusk defenses and
inside the Pentagon to put a stop to the
black tusk looting
I know this might seem like
[Applause]
however it didn't take long to find out
that they weren't just looting a few
extra toys to add to their arsenal there
was something far more important hadn't
deep down in the research labs of DARPA
the division fought through the hordes
of black tusks and made their way
through the Pentagon where they
eventually found themselves face-to-face
with a new type of drone that the BTS
who had brought along with them after
taking it down and downloading the BTS u
Intel we first hear of something called
a perfusion bioreactor and that the
black tasks were attempting to extract
from the site this is a profusion
bioreactor thanks to you we've got
broad-spectrum antiviral medication that
can prevent another outbreak but we
don't have anywhere near enough to go
around
this thing will solve that problem it's
essential that we recover it but there's
another problem we need to solve first
we're pretty sure black tusk is using
that drill to extract the bioreactor
they definitely don't want us to have it
so disappoint them wreck their plans do
whatever it takes to make sure that
equipment ends up in the right hands
essentially the perfusion bioreactor
along with the broad-spectrum antiviral
is the solution to the worldwide
pandemic this device would allow
authorities to create the antiviral and
large quantities and it's speed
the construction of the bioreactor has
been going on for some time potentially
even before the virus was first released
in New York City from the recordings
that could be found around the site
staff working for DARPA we're preparing
to leave for the upcoming Christmas
holiday break but was stranded due to
the outbreak spreading and the following
lockdowns that have been put in place
across the country looking good Sara's
talking about quarantine procedures
maybe I ought to say an apology for the
scathing voicemail I just left our
department head
well [ __ ] I didn't expect the virus to
hit us here I heard both bill and mica
came down with the flu and that's why
everyone's quarantined ya have some
really bad news both for them and for
the project it's gonna take so much
longer to dry everything done with these
restrictions yes that's what they get
for having an office affair cold now my
fault they decided to start cheating
with each other and came down with $1.00
flu eventually the Dola fluid made its
way into the Washington DC non-essential
Pentagon staff was sent home while
others left behind were pushed to
complete the bioreactor
all while being completely unaware of
whether there would even be an antiviral
ready in time do you think we'll
actually get this reactor built yeah but
I have my doubts that will have the
antiviral can't manufacture doses of a
vaccine without the vaccine do you think
the dct won't find a solution we still
don't have a vaccine for AIDS and that's
been killing people for 30 years
and with her
I think we're done give the seals
another check
I've been over them four times
everything's buttoned up no harm in
checking again the DCD still doesn't
have an antiviral that's effective yet
fine at least the work keeps me from
thinking about how bad things really are
what they're evacuating the staff our
parts done reactors built and tested I
kind of figured they'd keep us on in
case they need to run it
you've seen the sera reports the
government is all but gone the
president's dead the feet offed himself
no one is coming to save us this is the
end times I've had enough of your
negativity the black tusk we're using a
huge drill to dig down into the DARPA
labs blow to extract the bioreactor the
division was able to fight down into the
dark labs and attempted to extract the
bioreactor themselves there was heavy
black tusk resistance including
automated turrets and even Brenner
himself
fortunately the division was successful
in pushing through and the reactor was
extracted through maintenance tunnels
and then by a helicopter the path that
the black tusks were also considering if
the drilling operation failed
this changes everything well it will if
we're gonna produce enough antivirals to
make a difference and be sure that what
we produce is effective and safely we
need someone who knows what they're
doing to supervise the entire process we
can't afford to take risks but that's a
problem for tomorrow today let's
celebrate your victory because it's a
big one
this seems pretty obvious to me that
we'll be seeing another familiar face
soon dr. candle was heavily involved
with creating the antivirus so she would
be the best candidate to run this
operation the division now have both the
broad-spectrum antibiotics and the
perfusion bioreactor in their hands and
are being stored at the base of
operations in the White House this
device as discussed earlier is capable
of producing the broad-spectrum
antibiotic when the fight against the
doll flu to be fair we still can't be
sure that the broad-spectrum antiviral
actually works we just have to take the
word on it for now plus dr. candle from
New York City was working on it and
she's a tough cookie so I'm sure this
one has been properly tested unlike some
of the other solutions that have come
out DZ 62 for this one time offer you
two can get the cure-all it's still
uncertain as to what the BTS you wanted
with the antiviral and the bioreactor
perhaps to use as leverage
well maybe to be seen as saviors as they
are trying to create some sort of New
World Order and if they were seem to be
the ones who cured the world pandemic
rather than the current government who
would certainly help garner the support
of the public with Brina did they've
lost a powerful officer but we need to
keep in mind that this is the black tusk
special unit or BTS you this unit led by
Barton Shafer is in charge of the black
tusk operations happening in DC this is
just one unit of the full black tusk
organization from the story so far they
appear to be a worldwide organization or
at the very least have branches spread
across the rest of the United States we
have far from putting a stop to the
black tusk plans and we still don't know
who the organization is or who employed
them in the first place given their size
and strength it would seem a little
strange by now having been stopped by
the division at both tidal basin and now
the Pentagon that they aren't
considering a counter-attack we've seen
how defenseless we are at the base of
operations who wouldn't seem like too
big a task for an organization like the
black tusk to assault and reclaim what
they've been fighting for
I see if this going one of two ways the
black tasks will soon launch an attack
on the White House or perhaps the
division are predicting this and decided
to relocate abandoning the White House
altogether we already know by now that
we're traveling back to New York in
search of Aaron kena so given the
pressure that the division are now under
and what they have to protect from the
black tusk why are they even interested
in Eric Weiner at this moment in time
what does he have to do with all of this
I have my theories some have talked
about before some have been going on and
on about for a long time now and some
have been mocked for because of how out
there they seem hey I feel like that's
my job to open up people's minds to the
possibilities and potential directions
that the story could go no matter how
crazy they seem but I won't be talking
about it in this video
the next video will dive a little deeper
into what can be found in the DARPA labs
and will be a little more speculation
and theory based there's a lot going on
down there
I think it's time for the tinfoil hat to
come out before I go I have a tiny
little channel update very recently I
started dropping the odd stream odd
being the appropriate word
this isn't with the intention of cutting
into my already very limited video
making time it's more of an extra if I'm
in game mucking about looking for Intel
or maybe just farming to improve my
builds with the balancing updates from
time to time I'll be checking on the
stream so I can have a bit of a yarn
warning though I can play these games
pretty well and I love a good chat but
together I can't seem to do either
particularly well so don't come
expecting expert gameplay packaged
together with some fantastic banter
you'll be severely disappointed create
two actual streamers it's a tough gig
you'll also notice that win live I'm not
quite as calm and collected as you see
in my videos strangely enough I actually
like to have some fun while I'm playing
games I'll be playing this mission for
like two hours now hang on what is it
yep two hours there you go it cooks
house ten kills I have eight and you
have 200
yep I have a laugh that will give small
children nightmares no apologies no
seriously my full-blown laugh actually
makes my three-month-old cry feelsbadman
anyway I'll have a link to my twitch
channel in the description come by and
say hello when you see me on I'll
probably recognize a few of you from the
comments if you've made it this far
thank you very much for watching this
video and I'll catch you in the next one
Cheers
[Music]